joli tu m'a frappé tu viens de me
frapper et au
regard du mahdi le mag des vidéos du
procès kéké sur tic toc est en
permanence en permanence en permanence à
la télévision évidemment parlé
mais tout ce qui
est vous savez qu'il a aussi des
bookmakers là bas aux états unis comme
mon vote surtout on est des bookmakers
pour l'instant john johnny johnny depp
est un petit peu de vent mais tu peux tu
peux voter sur general voilà moi je suis
à fond team johnny vous tente il quelque
chose ainsi mais j'imagine que et gens
vivaient timber tu peux d'autant plus
voter que cette année enfin ce procès
est retransmis en direct avec la fin là
type de streaming netflix et ses
reprises sur youtube surtout sur twitch
etc et on peut assister à tout ce qui se
dit du début jusqu'à la fin mais comment
peut-elle belge pour une question gagner
encore quand on sait que l avez dit qe2
c'est d'abord le depuis premier jour
aller chez lui à l'enregistrer tout
quelle femme fait ça 2 quant à lui des
coûts elle a dit que tu es macheda cas
maquillage et
petit roi pour se défendre elle a cité
l'intégralité d'un film avec matt damon
qui était en fait une reprise de plein
soleil avec avec anna de long pour se
défendre un professeur il plaît quelques
mois cette fille peut encore gagner
en fait ce qui est intéressant dans ce
double procès parce qu on a déjà eu il
ya deux ans et qu'en fait c'est johnny
depp qui a tap des propos en diffamation
qu'elle a demandé journaux l'as et dans
le washington post donc aux etats unis
c'est pour ça que le procès ait lieu là
bas et qu'il est diffusé à la télévision
et ce qui est hyper intéressant c'est
que justement tout et des balais pour la
première fois notamment l'huile il
accuse de lui avoir coupé le doigt avec
une bouteille de vodka il l'accuse de
l'avoir trompé avec hélène magnifique et
dans son lit ouais ça c'est dans le
précédent à pardonner et ce qui est
hyper intéressant c'est que c'est pas
vraiment une histoire d'argent en fait
lui aujourd'hui ce qu'il veut c'est
redorer son image s'il a peur d'un
contrat disney il a perdu son contrôle
routier c'est de la perte du contrat
disney t ça commence à ses élèves parce
que le film s'est également toutes les
franchises qui en retour un sourire et
ce n'est ces trois dit stella ses 221
millions de dollars qu'il a perdu une
paille mais ce chaos
mais l'intégration c'est comme quand
même c'est qu'elle est en perte de
vitesse avait pas mal et qu'elle sait
que c'est évidemment filmer le code
visuel elle apparaît volontairement des
fêtes masque avec nettement moins de
maquillage sept mois alors que c'est une
jeune femme qui est constamment à prêter
et là il ya vraiment regardé comme il
m'a détruite regard des individus mais
est ce qu'on n'est pas en train
d'assister à un petit excès de mythes ou
dans l'autre sens ce qui est en train de
faire du mal à me tout en maintenant des
filles soient serbes noces armée
totalement et amber heard ailleurs
l'avait prévenu elle avait dit tu crois
vraiment qu'on va croire que tu as un
mec battue et il a d'ailleurs pu prouver
dupuis me pu montrer ce message qu'elle
eut envoyé mais où elle a quand même
réussi un petit peu à a écorché à faire
craquer le vernis johnny cette semaine
c'est en parlant de sa fille avec
vanessa paradis et du fait que son papa
les initier un peu à la marijuana qu'il
est toléré qu'elle ait une relation à la
même époque où lily rose soit qu'elle
avait 14 ans elle fréquente est un homme
lit énormément plus âgé qu'elle et à qui
l'autorisait de passer la nuit donc là
j'avoue que sur sur la drogue aux états
unis ça rigole pas et là je pense qu'il
s'est pris une petite renommée